salut à tous bienvenue dans europe hebdo
nous sommes à bruxelles au parlement
européen dans cette émission je vous
emmène au pays bas là bas depuis
quelques années les services sociaux ont
mis en place une politique pragmatique
pour gérer les personnes sans domicile
fixe moyennant quelques euros et des
canettes de bière les sdf nettoie chaque
jour les parcs et les rues de la ville
une action qui a suscité la polémique
mais qui a toutefois permis à des
dizaines de personnes précaires
d'entamer leur réinsertion
mais d'abord l'actualité nouveau round
de négociations pour le ttp le traité
transatlantique fin avril à washington
et pour fêter ça les entités ip organise
une journée internationale de
mobilisation ce samedi
alors le traité est il mort né c'est la
question de la semaine
ah tiens ça faisait longtemps revoilà le
type le tartare le gmt quoi le traité
transatlantique
mais si ce traité dont personne ne veut
mais que la commission européenne
continue vaillamment de négocier un
nouveau round de négociations s'ouvrent
fin avril à washington et pour fêter ça
les antilles type prévoit une journée
internationale de mobilisation
il faut dire que le collectif stop
taffetas prend de l'ampleur 1,5 million
de signatures pour l'initiative
citoyenne création de milliers de
collectifs locaux multiplication des
actions locales explosion du nombre de
débats alors le type est il mort né
le type est il mort né pour répondre à
cette question c'est yannick jadot que
j'ai le plaisir de recevoir bonjour je
vous êtes vice président de la
commission du commerce international ici
au parlement députés verts pour vous et
yannick est ce que ce traité est mort né
à quoi ça sert encore de négocier il est
pas mort mais malheureusement parce que
l'ensemble de comme vous le dites dans
le sujet la commission européenne
continue à négocier avec
l'administration obama
mais c'est vrai qu'il a du plomb dans l
aile du plomb dans l aile en europe
parce que des centaines de région de
ville se sont déclarés zones hors castes
à ce qu'elle voit bien que leurs
compétences pour être contestée par
traité transatlantique que au parlement
européen il ya une une mobilisation
croissante contre une partie de cet
accord qui est l'idée que les
investisseurs les entreprises pourra
attaquer les états devant des tribunaux
privée donc sortir des juridictions
classiques pour aller devant des
tribunaux privé est demandée
potentiellement des milliards d'euros
dédommagement ses profits qui ne vont
pas faire il y à des millions de
citoyens qui sont mobilisés parce qu'au
fond ce traité il à jette finalement il
inquiète parce que le libre-échange avec
les états-unis c'est déjà un fait ce qui
se négocie dans ce traité c'est la
capacité des états des régions ou de
l'union européenne ou du niveau fédéral
aux états unis de réguler de défendre de
réguler sur la santé sur l'environnement
sur les droits sociaux
mais dans les libertés numériques la
commission justement dit qu' il est hors
de question d'accepter en fait de
baisser les normes européennes pour
aller vers les normes américaines par
exemple sur les questions
environnementales dans les questions
sociales sur les questions de liberté
etc
donc vous avez quand même eu des gages
vous avez un groupe spécial qui a été
constituée et si au parlement européen
avec des députés qui suit de près le
développement le développement des
négociations h après chaque ramener
avant chaque rentes vous voyez les
négociateurs vous avez quand même obtenu
dégage alors pourquoi est-ce qu'on
refuse tout de go en fait cette négo
mais parce que ces gages
ils ne correspondent à rien si on lance
une négociation avec les états unis pour
faire converger les normes nos règles
en matière de santé d'environnement
d'agriculture d'alimentation de service
public de protection de la vie privée
avec les données personnelles
si on lance cette négociation pour faire
converger les normes c'est bien que les
normes et d'un côté de l'atlantique et
de l'autre vont bouger sinon lance pas
une négociation dans les services
financiers
c'est plutôt les américains qui ont des
normes plus strictes que les nôtres qui
réguler davantage les banques
l'objectif de l'union européenne c'est
de faire de casser ces régulations plus
strictes américaine pour servir la city
dans les médicaments aux états unis sont
plutôt plus strictes en europe
en revanche on le sait que dans
l'agriculture sur les hormones de
croissance sur les ogm sur les poulets
chlorés sur le principe de précaution
tout ça ils ne comprennent pas
donc ils veulent que l'europe baisse les
normes si personne ne bouge si tout le
monde garantie que les normes vont pas
bouger donc on est à la négociation
donc il ya bien une contradiction
majeure pour rudy l'union européenne la
commission européenne c'est qu'au fond
négocier de manière commerciale des
choix de société qui ont été
démocratiquement construit en plus
largement dans l'opacité
c'est forcément les faire évoluer soit
la baisse ou de toute façon nous
empêcher d'en acquérir de nouvelles ou
de faire évoluer celles qui existent
alors on parle quand même de 120
milliards d'euros par an de croissance
additionnelle alors ça ça les chiffres
de la commission européenne en ces temps
de crise on en a quand même un peu
besoin non à mai mois qu'on essaye de
développer les activités économiques on
fasse des échanges
ça ne me pose pas de problème
l'évaluation de la commission européenne
elle lit au fond si on réduit l'écart
entre les normes européennes et les
normes américaines c'est à dire qu'au
fond on bouge nos normes
on va avoir un gain annuel de 0,03 %
0,03 pour cent de croissance
additionnelle par an donc c'est vraiment
pas grand chose en plus ces études sont
controversés il ya une étude américaine
indépendante qui dit au contraire ça va
tuer détruire
six cent mille emplois en europe cent
trente mille emplois en france
donc on est sur des évaluations
économiques qui sont pas à la mesure
choix de société qu on serait obligé
d'abandonner simplement pour que
quelques grandes multinationales fasse
un peu plus de profit alors il ya un
autre traité qui se profile c'est le
tiza dont on entend très peu parler donc
là c'est sous l'égide de l'organisation
mondiale du commerce est il très très en
fait l'appareil on est dans la
négociation aussi donc de libre échange
aussi certainement mais avec 50 pays du
monde pour qu'on n'entend pas parler on
entend pas parler parce que la
négociation est encore plus obscure
encore plus opaque
il ya effectivement une cinquantaine de
pays dont l'union européenne mais il
n'ya pas les pays émergents il n'y a pas
la chine afrique du sud le brésil et
puis ça ne concerne que les services
mais là encore on est sur des dangers
extraordinaire parce que prenons
l'exemple de l'assurance maladie
tout le monde dit à mes l'assurance
maladie vous inquiétez pas on va pas y
toucher c'est un service public de la
santé
non l'assurance maladie c'est considérer
dans cette négociation comme un service
financier comme un service d'assurance
donc qu'on peut le libéraliser et puis à
cette idée que à chaque fois que vous
avez libéralisé vous avez marchandises
et un service et bien au fond vous
pouvez pu revenir en arrière donc toutes
ces mairies qui essayent de
remunicipaliser exagération de l'os
comme ça ne pourrait plus loin donc
c'est vraiment encore une fois la remise
en cause des capacités des collectivités
d état ou de l'union européenne a décidé
de choix de société a décidé de la
protection des citoyens plutôt que
l'intérêt des multinationales alors on
change complètement de ce sujet je
voudrais vous faire écouter un petit
échange une pompe entre vladimir poutine
et alexis tsipras ce on l'écouté
il n'est pas question dead mais de
coopération y compris dans le domaine
financier en lien avec de grands projets
concrets la grèce n'est pas un mendiant
qui va chercher des solutions à ses
problèmes financiers
en passant d'un pays à un autre pour un
problème qui ne concerne pas seulement
la grèce mais l'europe ce n'est pas un
problème grec
c'est un problème européen est un
problème européen solution européenne
yannick jadot quelle est votre lecture
de cette visite d' alexis tsipras savent
la dernière poutine on est là dans une
espèce d'alliance un peu contre nature
ou une alliance contre nature parce que
effectivement on sait les amitiés qui
entrera certain nombre de membres de
syriza et le leadership poutine
je la trouve contre nature parce que le
leadership poutine c'est une oligarchie
corrompue dictatorial qui est en guerre
au qui mène une guerre en europe en
revanche qui serait terrible et
heureusement si prince tombe pas dans ce
piège c'est que l'europe ne trouve pas
la solution à la question grecque comme
la grecque la grèce ne trouvait pas une
solution avec l'europe à ses problèmes
économiques
la pire des choses ce serait que
finalement ce soit pas l'europe qui aide
à sortir de l'actrice d'humanité en
grèce qui aide la grèce à investir et
aussi à lutter contre l'évasion fiscale
contre la corruption mais qu'au fond la
solution vienne l'argent du pétrole et
de la russie m pour espérer qu'on en
n'arrivera jamais là parce que ce serait
un incroyable échec pour l'europe qu'au
fond syriza et le gouvernement grec ait
besoin de l'argent russe pour sortir de
la panade c'est la responsabilité
européenne d'aider la grèce est d'aider
la grèce à se sortir elle même à faire
les réformes nécessaires notamment en
matières d'évasion fiscale bon bah
écoute et merci à négocier le mot de la
fin
nous on continue direction les pays-bas
depuis quelques années une politique un
petit peu nouvelle pragmatique pour
gérer les
sdf moyennant quelques bières et
quelques euros ils nettoient les parcs
et les rues de la ville et pour certains
cela permet de revenir un petit peu à la
réinsertion reportage de fleurance
hommage
fred vient tous les jours dans ce local
à l'abri des regards
c'est l'un des vins sdf qui participent
à un projet un peu particulier depuis
deux ans une association financée par
des fonds publics offrent bière
cigarettes repas chauds et petits
salaires à ces sans abri en échange ils
sont chargés de nettoyer le parc dans
lequel il avait l'habitude de passer
leur journée
j'ai commencé à boire en 1979 j'ai
arrêté les drogues dures et je suis
passé à l'alcool
c'était bière genièvre et whisky à
volonté fred n'a pas été épargné par la
vie j'ai perdu les trois femmes que j'ai
aimé la première s'est suicidé la
deuxième est morte d'un cancer de
l'estomac est la troisième d'une
hémorragie cérébrale
l'objectif est de remettre ces sdf sur
les rails
aux pays bas on ne s'embarrasse pas de
questions philosophiques et plutôt
qu'interdire on préfère encadrer les
sans abri afin de mieux les canaliser ça
c'est le registre où je note ce que
chacun consomme c'est moi qui distribue
les bières aussi étrange que cela puisse
paraître on travaille aussi sur le
problème de l'alcoolisme
s'il travaille il reçoit 24 euros et
cinq cannettes de bière répartis dans la
journée mais s'ils veulent arrêter on
les aide à se désintoxiquer
au lieu de leur offrir de la bière on
leur donne une prime de 10 euros en bons
d'achat au bout de quatre jours
d'abstinence au départ fred venait pour
la bière mais depuis un mois et demi il
n'a pas touché une goutte d'alcool
j'étais tous les jours dans le parc je
buvais bière après bière maintenant j'ai
décidé d'arrêter l'alcool mais il suffit
d'une goutte pour que je rechute on
nettoie ion le parc on sait qu'on fait
quelque chose pour la société en
attendant de se remettre sur les rails
comme ça on traîne pas dans la rue et on
se sent utile pour la mairie de secteur
ce projet est une opportunité
cela a permis de vider le parc de ces
sdf clip audio
il y a beaucoup de gens qui ont envie de
profiter du parc de la verdure
mais si une grande partie du parc est
occupé par des sdf qui boivent de la
bière toute la journée
c'est gênant pour les riverains car ils
font du bruit laissent leurs canettes
traîner maintenant viennent nettoyer le
parc et c'est un très bon projet à mes
yeux
dans les rues d'amsterdam il y a peu de
sdf ici la mendicité est interdite par
arrêté préfectoral
aux pays-bas la question des sans abri
est centralisée au niveau des communes
des crédits spécifiques qui sont gérés
et coordonner de manière très efficace
l'objectif est de travailler en amont
pour que personne ne deviennent sans
abri au sein du restaurant de la mairie
d'amsterdam
on emploie des mères célibataires en
difficulté qu'est ce que vous apprenez
ici qu'est ce que ça vous apporte
j'apprends à communiquer à servir les
clients
j'apprends aussi sur moi même
claudia à 24 ans elle a un fils de 2 ans
dans cette société si tu ne fais rien tu
n'avances pas au mieux faire par contre
si tu travailles alors tu te construis
expérience amsterdam est une grande
ville et il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont
du mal à joindre les deux bouts
la coalition qui dirige la ville a
décidé de consacrer 80 millions d'euros
à la lutte contre la pauvreté malgré les
moyens mis en oeuvre certains passent à
travers les mailles du filet ce foyer
flambant neuf
accueil des sans abri dans cinquante et
une chambre cela coûte 5 euros la nuit
certains vivent depuis des années dans
la rue ils viennent ici pour dix nuits
pour récupérer un peu mais il ya
d'autres personnes qui sont sans abri
juste pour quelques mois et qui cherche
un endroit où dormir à 60 ans anna a pas
mal bourlingué
elle était sans domicile fixe en france
avant de revenir à amsterdam sa ville
natale
c'est temporaire mais c'est
facile quand même il ya beaucoup de
structures ici en france je ne sais pas
mais je vois beaucoup plus légendaires
je pense que la politique la politique
ici à amsterdam
c'est de l'entendre le plus de plus le
plus possible invisible le fait que
saisit à des essais car aujourd'hui dans
les rues d'amsterdam les sans abri sont
devenus invisibles
l'attitude des néerlandais à l'égard des
sdf semble avant tout dictés par le
pragmatisme
ici on préfère organiser le phénomène au
grand jour plutôt que laisser les gens
dormir dehors
et voilà pour ce reportage à amsterdam
et pour en débattre c'est
marie-christine vergiat que je reçois
bonjour jour et elisabeth morin-chartier
merci d'être avec nous mesdames première
question est ce que ça vous choque ce
qui se passe aux pays-bas ce le fait de
donner quelques canettes de bières et
quelques euros et des vêtements à
tartiner n'ont absolument pas parce que
on n'est pas dans l'interdiction on ne
sort pas d'un diction par l'interdiction
on sort de la diction par une
reconstruction personnelle
d'ailleurs vous savez je trouve beaucoup
de similitudes entre ce reportage et les
méthodes employées
est ce que nous faisons pour les sorties
sans qualification
la reconstruction personnelle elle est
essentielle on ne peut pas sortir les
gens d'une addiction pareil par simple
décret mais là le fait que ce soit la
puissance publique ma christine vergiat
qui distribue les bières est-ce que
c'est pas un symbole un peu un peu
limite
je vais faire des comparaisons avec un
débat d'actualité en france c'est la
question des salles de shoot enfouis
c'est vrai c'est qu'ils ont été
autorisés les salles de shoot c'est
exactement la même chose
est ce qu'on prend en main le problème
est qu'on essaye de réinsérer ces
populations de les ramener à une vie
normale parce qu'ils détruisent leur vie
en
en général et on s'en donne les moyens
et effectivement on passe par des phases
des phases de ce jardin le côté carottes
bâton là me gêne un peu il ya un peu de
contrôle social aussi derrière mais bon
le danemark est un des pays qui a les
meilleurs résultats avec la finlande je
crois en matière de pauvreté la suède
les pays scandinaves en général
d'ailleurs les pays d'europe du nord 1
qui ont le moins de personnes à la rue
en difficulté et plus largement en
situation d'exclusion sociale
lorsqu'il ya les sans abri et il ya les
personnes qui vivent en dessous du seuil
de pauvreté il ya les personnes qui sont
en risque d'exclusion comme on dit dans
le langage européen et qui représente
quand même 25 % de la population
européenne donc ce n'est pas tout à fait
rien tous ne sont pas sans abri je crois
que si ma mémoire est bonne c'est à peu
près deux millions de personnes sans
abri en en europe
mais si on ne veut pas que les gens se
retrouvent à la rue et avoir des
méthodes qui coûte beaucoup plus cher
d'ailleurs le meilleur moyen c'est de
prévenir et de ne pas faire des
politiques qui conduisent à des
situations de pauvreté
on voit que les événements à chartier la
situation s'est considérablement
aggravée depuis la crise de 2008
bien sûr en france alors je sais les
chiffres absolument hallucinant le
nombre de sans domicile fixe a augmenté
de 44% en 11 ans passant de 81 mille à
150000 perversion vous avez totalement
raison et les publics ont changé ouais
c'est à dire beaucoup plus de fragilité
des femmes après la crise a sorti des
femmes du travail elle était sur des
contrats précaires
elle était sur des temps partiels et est
sur des niveaux de rémunérations
extrêmement faible par rapport aux
sommes donc les femmes ont été beaucoup
plus tôt chez les jeunes vont
extrêmement touchée et fait le rapport
aussi le parallèle avec la montée du
chômage les jeunes leurs difficultés à
rentrer dans le premier emploi et on
s'est beaucoup de famille et ses amis et
parfois des familles pour la deuxième
génération
donc on voit bien qu'il ya un phénomène
qui s'est ancrée dans notre population
c'est la raison pour laquelle moi je
suis pas du tout choquée pour à part le
fait que les politiques publiques
s'empare de ces problèmes et y compris
en surveillant les consommations et dont
la consommation d'alcool mais alcool
drogue viennent à dents serrées ce
cercle ce cercle vicieux et mais je vous
rappelle qu'il a fallu quand même que le
parlement européen bataille très
sérieusement pour que nous préservions
dans le fonds social européen 20%
spécialement dédié à la lutte contre la
pauvreté parce que les chefs d'état et
de gouvernement au niveau européen
qu'ils soient de droite ou de gauche ça
n'est pas une question de parti
politique
c'était une question j'allais dire de
volonté de politique européenne de tapis
dur pour prendre en charge cette
question et c'est grâce au parlement
européen que nous avons pu le faire
parce que le parlement s'est opposé à ce
que voulait faire
les chefs d'état et de gouvernement sur
ce point justement est-ce qu'on n'est
pas un petit peu timide sur les
politiques mises en oeuvre au niveau
européen sur ces questions de grande
précarité
on est un peu timide et j'ajouterais ce
que vient de dire elisabeth morin
chartier qui a fallu batailler pour
sauvegarder le programme d'aidé
alimentaire est quand même là bas
le b à ba quand exactement quand on a
fait des coupes sombres dans le budget
européen des coupes claires d'ailleurs
pardon on a taillé sur les programmes
les plus
les plus sociaux kwh est donc crucial
d'ailleurs quand on est engagé avant
siam l'adapter un d'amener mon livre moi
c'est un rapport du parlement européen
une étude
ouais européen sur les conséquences de
la crise économique et sociale des
politiques d'austérité en matière de
droits fondamentaux
ouais et on voit dans ce rapport qui est
un rapport officiel fait par les
services du parlement européen donc non
politique on voit en quoi ça a aggravé
la polis et la pauvreté toucher aux
droits les plus fondamentaux le droit à
la santé de droit à l'éducation le droit
au logement
donc on est on est on est pas assez à
laon et j'irai au delà de ce que dit
elizabeth
il ya un fonds spécifique pour les plus
démunis dans le problème c'est deux
milliards et demi d'euros
dit comme ça deux milliards et demi
d'euros ça paraît énorme main sur 25 de
la population européenne voilà en
millions ça représente 2 milliards et
demi d'euros pour 25% de la population
en pleine et 0,25 pour cent du budget de
l'union européenne
donc moi je pense que là en la matière y
aurait des priorités à elisabeth mans il
ya un point sur lequel je veux insister
c'est que aujourd'hui à 19 millions
d'européens qui ne mangent pas un repas
avec des protéines tous les deux jours
bon ça ça pose question
parce qu' il n'est pas question de
situer de calculer un niveau de pauvreté
j'allais dire très très éthéré en
comptant le nombre de la vaisselle le
nombre de téléviseurs et tout ça ça
c'est un point mais quand on touche à
l'alimentation à l'apport en protéines
dans l'alimentation
on voit bien que en europe il y a aussi
une extrême pauvreté et cette pauvreté
elle est devenue beaucoup plus jeune
ouais moi j'ai des épiceries sociales
que je soutiens dans des universités en
france
bon on repart exemple non mais on voit
pas les devenu beaucoup plus rural
y avait en france par exemple l'idée que
la misère est moins difficile à la
campagne parce qu'on a toujours un petit
jardin etc
c'est pas vrai aujourd'hui on a des
agriculteurs qui bénéficient du fonds d
aide aux plus démunis
non on voit bien que il y a eu un
ancrage beaucoup plus fort et que la
situation est devenue extrêmement
difficile c'est pour ça qu'il faut
vraiment alors insisté pour que l'europe
soit leader dans six explosions sur
cette question l'un des intervenants de
notre reportage avait une question
directe à vous poser je souhaiterais
qu'on écoute
si vous voulez une politique européenne
de lutte contre la pauvreté et la
précarité
il est très important qu'on se mette
d'accord sur ce dont on parle
la façon dont on mesure au niveau
européen la pauvreté et l'exclusion
c'est à dire le seuil de pauvreté
relatif de 60% du revenu médian n'est
pas adapté à mes yeux je recommande
qu'on aille plus loin en comparant ce
dont les gens ce dans les différents
états membres ont réellement besoin pour
ne pas être pauvres
ceci implique de regarder le revenu dont
ils ont besoin pour se loger se nourrir
s'éclairer des fautes en électricité à
tort selon ce participant
alors clairement elisabeth morin
chartier le problème peut-être vient de
là c'est que les standards ne sont pas
les mêmes qu'on soit dans l'ouest de
l'europe dans l'est au sud au nord donc
à quand une vision un petit peu claire
nette précise du niveau de pauvreté au
niveau européen d'abord il ya plusieurs
niveaux de pauvreté que l'on peut
mesurer et c'est un peu ce que nous
avons dit est l'une et l'autre depuis le
début de cette émission est ce que on
est dans la dans le standard moyen de
pauvreté dans ce cas là on compte le
téléphone le téléviseur le lave
vaisselle etc
est-ce qu'on est dans l'alimentation -
qui pour moi est le coeur même de notre
premier combat à mener il ya des enfants
aujourd'hui en france qui mange parce
que il mange à la craquante sionneau est
bon qu'ils n'ont pas de petit déjeuner
etc
il ya des enfants qui ne vont même plus
à la demi pension parce que la demi
pension est trop cher donc on est là au
coeur même à l'épi son voile alimentera
elle est aussi la question de la
précarité énergétique et que le niveau
des loyers notamment dans les pcgr
européenne joue énormément bien sûr et
là et là je dois vous dire que la
réponse n'est pas seulement une réponse
d'être aussi con ce décramponne d'un
certain nombre de dépendance énergétique
et je pense en particulier
moi je mets beaucoup d'espoir sur le
nouvel oléoduc qui va venir d'afrique du
nord et qui va nous apporter
42 % de l'énergie aujourd'hui qu'on
importe de la russie oui
donc vous voyez nergie scellé à lier
danse énergétique
il faut se décomposer tout ça il faut
pouvoir aussi faire à jouer alors votre
concurrence
marie christine vergiat sur cette
question est ce que là typiquement sait
on voit bien que le logement n'est pas
aussi une compétence européenne
comment est-ce qu'on peut agir de
manière pragmatique sur ces questions au
niveau européen c'est vrai que c'est
et c'est assez compliqué parce qu'on
n'est pas dans les compétences du roi la
rue européenne
on est dans la méthode ouverte de
concertation la moc comme on dit donc ça
dépend de la bonne volonté des états
donc les bataille que mène notamment le
parlement européen sur ces questions
c'est d'aller de l'avant de pousser et
monsieur monsieur la raison c'est aller
de l'avant aussi dans la mesure où ce
que pour comparer les choses et je
trouve moi qu'on a plutôt avancé au
niveau européen en la matière parce que
on mesure le
le seuil de pauvreté désormais c'est
bien 60% dans tous les revenus médians
dans tous les états membres ce n'est pas
le cas avant donc on sait que les
personnes menacées de d'exclusion les
appelle c'est ceux qui sont autour de
60% du revenu médian calculé dans chaque
état membre
c'est important parce qu'il y avait
quand même oui mais après nord les
tolérances et un deuxième élément y
compris pour répondre à ça quand vous
regardez les statistiques justement on
tient compte non seulement du rheu du
revenu médian mais aussi des questions
de privations matérielles
quand on dit 120 millions de personnes
dont 25 millions d'enfants d'ailleurs
sont menacés d'exigence et ça donc on
pousse au parlement européen à mettre en
oeuvre ce qu'on appelle des stratégies
européennes ou des cadres européens pour
des stratégies nationales pour que les
états membres nous avec moi elle avant
le principe de subsidiarité c'est à dire
leurs compétences propres pour aller de
l'avant et il faut la taille en est une
bien sûr que non seulement on veut on
pousse à mettre en une un cadre européen
pour les sans abri pour le moment il
il est voté au parlement mais un point
final très rapidement deux choses
premièrement nous avons besoin niveau du
parlement européen d'une forte cohésion
entre tous les groupes politiques point
là c'est pourquoi et c'est mon deuxième
point parce que les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement sont très très peu enclin
sur à aller sur les politiques sociales
il préfère faire du béton il préfère
faire du bitume il nous faut de
l'aménagement du territoire c'est vrai
mais il nous faut de l'emploi mais quand
même politique sociale sont
indispensables très rapidement
juste une phrase j'ai mené ce rapport
parce que son rapport ce rapport
démontre que les politiques publiques
sont essentiels toutes les politiques
publiques menées depuis cinq ans étape
sur les coupes budgétaires les frappent
les plus vulnérables la première en
première ligne notamment les femmes
notamment les enfants notamment les
personnes âgées
j'ai notamment les personnes handicapées
et en prime les migrants écoutez donc le
tuera là dessus merci beaucoup mais dame
d'avoir accepté d'en parler avec nous
nous on se quitte mais avant cela
j'aurais souhaité vous parler de cet
ouvrage qui vient de sortir
ilike europe caroline gillet amélie
fontaine un conseil de lecture pour les
prochaines vacances de pâques et merci à
tous d'avoir été avec nous on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine à bientôt